uh
hi can you hear me yeah um
hi i'm mary i'm going to talk about isla
which is a programming language i've
been making for
young children so i'm going to talk
about designing a language for children
i'm going to talk about the compiler
that i wrote that runs the language
i'm going to talk about teaching my
girlfriend and my dad to program
and i'm going to speak about modes of
expression
um but first i'll take you through your
first
program written in isla code
so eiler is a drummer uh
here she is hopefully yep
um that's my niece she's uh called isla
she likes the yankees um
she's two years old and her favorite
lunch is jelly tots which is a type of
english sweetie
here's some more people mary is a
guitarist and emma is a singer
and sophie is a pianist and here's a
list of isla's
aunties so we'll add mary to that list
emma and sophie
so let's review isla is a drummer she's
two years old
she loves jelly tots and she's got three
aunties a guitarist
a singer and a pianist
so designing a programming language for
children
um well first of all can children
program
um i feel like at age five which is the
lower bound of
the age range i'm aiming at for this
language
then at age five then children come
learning to read learning to write which
me
to me means they can input code at the
keyboard and read it off the screen
um and they can also reason as well
they've got the faculty of reasoning
so i've had some humiliating defeats at
the hands of my niece when
um debating whether she should be
allowed to have another jellytot or so
and then should children program well
computers are being used to make more
and more stuff and that's only going to
increase as time goes on
and also i think programming is the best
way to control a computer
and so i think a person makes something
to try and show what is inside their
head
and i think it's a really good thing for
people to show each other the insides of
their heads
and so should children program well if
computers are being used to make more
and more stuff
and programming is the best way to
control a computer then
to me programming is becoming like a
core skill the way we view
reading and writing and doing maths at
the moment and so
um i think programming should be learned
at the same time as all those skills i.e
from about age four or five
what are the opinions that i use to
guide the development of the language
well number one programming is typing so
programming is not clipping together
little jigsaw pieces that have code
written on them
um it's not manipulating blocks with a
gui
it's not using any kind of gui it's it's
it's typing words
into a computer um and the reason this
is important is
uh number one language is the best way
that humans have come up with
for expressing ideas in a powerful and
subtle way
um and number two there's this notion of
indirection which
is the reason that i think programming's
so fun so i type in something into the
computer here
um and then something happens over here
and in between there's magic
and that magic is fun but i'll come back
to that idea in a bit
number two uh the second opinion i took
was that
you should have an application for a
programming language it should be useful
for something so
i didn't want um kids just or anyone
just
typing in random code to instantiate
variables or print out the numbers
between one and a hundred
because that's really dull um they
should be able to make something with it
because that's the whole point of
programming to me is to
express yourself to actually make
something and so the application that i
chose to start with
was a old-school text adventure writing
environment so you can type isla code
and
you define your own old school text
adventure you know kind of like zork or
adventure or whatever
and then you can play through it so it's
interactive
but at the same time different heads
contain different things so
i didn't want to tie the core language
to
the particular application that i chose
the storytelling environment
and so i've tried to make it general so
that it could be conceivably used for
anything
and number four the fourth principle um
that i've used to guide the development
is to use baby talk
so what i mean by that is to try and
make the language
similar to how children actually speak
so that that means there's a few
ramifications of that so
number one there's no punctuation except
for the apostrophes that go around
strings
and that's because punctuation is hard
to
uh distinguish it's hard to distinguish
pieces of punctuation from each other
and it's also hard to type punctuation
because you often need to use the shift
key
number two is that
most programming languages use
programming jargon like
for or if or while or then
and i mean what the hell do they mean so
all of the keywords in isla
are words that a child would actually
use in the context that they used
and then number three is
the language is somewhat natural
language-ish
and my aim there is to try and make it
so that even if you don't know much code
even if you don't know how to code
you'll be able to read the language and
basically read a piece of code and
basically understand what's going on
but at the same time i'm trying to avoid
that trap that say applescript falls
into
where it looks like english and it gives
you the impression that you can just
type any random thing that comes into
your head
that's in english and the computer will
magically understand because of course
it won't
and so there's only one way to do
everything and it's very consistent
um and it's much closer to a sort of
pidgin english so i'm trying to avoid
that impression that you can just type
any random stuff that comes into your
head
so the isla compiler this is the thing
that the piece of code that goes from a
piece of either code
like this so write ila to actually
printing out ila at the console so how
do we get
from a piece of code to the result
well the compiler that i wrote takes a
two-stage process
does a two-stage uh process number one
parsing
number two interpreting so let's start
with parsing
parsing is taking that piece of code
which starts out as a completely
unstructured string
so just a list of characters and turning
it into a much more detailed recipe
called an abstract syntax tree which can
be used
to actually run the code so here is the
abstract syntax tree
for that piece of code that we just saw
a moment ago right isla
so this is going to print out eyelids of
the console nothing else
so let's go through it so at the top
level the whole thing's a tree
then you have an expression so the whole
piece of code is an expression
and then you can sub categorize that
expression as an invocation
which means you're running a function
and then that invocation
splits down into two components the
identifier which is the name of the
function you want to work
to run write w-r-i-t-e and then the
parameter
or the value which is the parameter
being passed to the function
which is euler and quotation marks and
then the value can be sub-categorized as
a literal
as opposed to a variable and then the
literal can be sub-categorized as a
string
as opposed to a number so
this is the end result of parsing so how
do we get there
we i use something called a parsing
expression grammar
or also known as a peg for short
and a parsi expression grammar is a list
of rules
which basically says on one side i've
got this thing
and i can decompose it as this
list of things here so let's take an
example
here's one of the parsing expression
grammar rules known as a production rule
and it says that an invocation can be
decomposed
into an identifier follow which is the
name of the
function you're going to run right
followed by space followed by a value
which is the name of the which is the
parameter
that you're passing to the function
followed by a new line character
so let's look at the parsing expression
grammar for
uh to parse this piece of code
so on the left we've got the grammar and
on the right we've got the
abstract syntax tree that comes out
which is the end of the passing stage
so we have to start with an expression
that's what the parsing expression
grammar says
okay let's pop that into the abstract
syntax tree
then the next rule says that an
expression must be an invocation
okay easy let's pop that into to the
abstract syntax tree
then the parsing expression grammar says
that an invocation
must be composed of an identifier
followed by a space followed by a value
followed by a newline character
as we saw a moment ago so let's take
those pieces one at a time
an identifier the parsing expression
grammar says must be
a list of lowercase letters more than
one lowercase letter
so that is right the name of the
function we're trying to run
and then the value the second part of
the invocation
the parsi expression grammar says that
that must be a literal
okay let's pop that in and then the
parsing expression grammar says that the
literal must be a string
and then it says that a string is an
apostrophe followed by zero or more
lowercase letters
followed by another apostrophe and so we
can pop that into the abstract syntax
tree
so we've parsed that piece of code we've
done the first stage
of the compilation process
so how does the pass function actually
work well we've done the hard work now
because
if you're using a parsing expression
grammar you're probably using a parsing
expression grammar library
i used one it's called peg.js it's
really nice i highly recommend it
and all you do is you give your list of
production rules your parsing expression
grammar
to the library and then it gives you
back a parser
and then you shovel code into your
parser and it gives you back the
abstract syntax tree so the path
function is trivial
next stage final stage is interpreting
so this is taking the recipe
that we've produced the abstract syntax
tree and essentially following the
instructions
which means running javascript code in
my case
um that is commensurate with the
instructions in the in the recipe
so here's the abstract syntax tree is
json
um let's look at it in a bit of detail
line two
is the first node the expression which
is remember the overarching node
of the whole tree um
the tag attribute says that it's of type
expression as opposed to an invocation
or an identifier
or a value or whatever and then the
content is every sub node
under it in the tree so the expression
node has ever
a whole of the rest of the tree
underneath it
now a quick aside the way the interpret
function works
is that essentially what you want to do
is you want to run different code
depending on what type of node you're
dealing with so you want to do something
different if you're running
if you're dealing with an expression
node in the abstract syntax tree
to if you're dealing with a string node
in the abstract syntax tree
now you could do this by
defining a bunch of classes and then
defining
a specific version of the interpret
function on each class
and that would totally work so you'd
have a class for an expression node
and a class for an identifier node and
so forth that would totally work but
it's a bunch of boilerplate and it's a
waste of time
another technique you can use is
multi-methods which is a functional
programming technique where you just
define the functions that you care about
so let's look at an example again we're
in javascript here
i used a library called multimeter.js
it's really nice
so it starts out on line one with
instantiating the interpret function
which is just a multi-method now
the way the multimeter decides which
version of itself to run
it decides based upon what the arguments
are that are passed into the function
so let's look at an example so this is
the piece of code that decides
which version of the multi-method to run
so remember we've got a version for
an expression node and a version for an
identifier node and so forth
we need to figure out which type of node
we're dealing with so we just look at
the node that gets passed in on line
three
look at the tag which will be a string
like expression or identifier
and return it so that's the dispatch
function
so then this is us defining the actual
interpret functions that we're going to
run
so on line 6 in the case of an
expression we do something
on line 10 in the case of an invocation
node
we do something else so let's look at
the real interpret function
same idea we've got a dispatch function
which tells us
which version of the function we want to
run and here's our first customer
line six the actual function that we run
for an expression node
so it's pretty simple line seven um we
look at the node
grab the content which in remember in
the case of an expression node is going
to be the whole of the rest of the tree
and then just call interpret again so we
recurse which will
result in running this function the
invocation function
so this is the invocation version of the
interpret function
and this is where the real stuff happens
so on line two we need to figure out
what the name of the function is we want
to run
so we need to figure out write w-r-i-t-e
how do we do that well it's pretty
trivial we just look at the node
on line two look at the content and then
grab the first element of the content
which is going to be the write
identifier
and then call interpret on it which
calls this version of the interpret
function for an identifier
which just returns the content of the
node which is just going to be the
string
right so bingo line two we've got our
function name
next line three we need to get the
actual function we want to run
so i've defined the write function which
just writes out the string you pass it
to the console
in javascript so we need to go and grab
that javascript function
how does that happen what's what's going
on here
um we can see something about an
environment
now the environment is the general
context that you're running
all of your eyelet code in and it
includes the actual context which is
where you store
all of the variables and functions that
are in scope currently
now that's where the write function
belongs the write function
and because that's a built-in it's a
function that's built right into eiler
it's available in at all times so we
need to go and grab the right function
from the execution context so that we
just get the environment which gets
passed into every invocation of the
interpret function
get the context off the environment look
up the function name
and bingo we've got the actual
javascript function we need to run
on the home stretch now we just need to
grab the parameter
which was going to pass to the right
function which is just remember it's ila
in apostrophes that's the thing we're
going to print out
so it's the second element of the
content of the invocation node
so we call interpret again that calls
the value version of interpret which
same same pattern look at the content
call interpret
that calls the literal version of
interpret same again
look at the content call interpret
finally here at last
we've got the actual thing we're looking
for where this is the string version of
the interpret function
and we look at the content of the node
which will just be
eyelet in apostrophes and pass that back
so now on line four we've got the
parameter we're trying to print out
then long last line five we can actually
run the function so you can see that we
just invoke fn
and pass in the parameter and that will
print out isla to the console
then it returns a return value which in
the case of the
write function is undefined
and then finally a bit of tidying up
because every
um every expression
can modify the environment we need to
return the new environment that resulted
from this
from this node being run now in our case
there's no
changes actually so the context just
stays as environment.context which is
what got passed in
and then we specify a return value
because expressions in either can return
values
but obviously in this case it's going to
be undefined so
uh that's basically the end of the code
um
teaching my girlfriend and my dad to
program this was really fun
um i as i said the eventual goal for
eiler is for it to be usable by
five-year-olds but that's a long way in
the future at the moment
as a stepping stone i'm using
non-programmers
who are non-technical people and which
includes
ellie and my dad to try the language out
on
so i set each of them down separately at
a
at an isla repel where you can just type
in pieces of isla code
um and we work through it so this is
ellie
um she typed right my name is ellie in
apostrophes
which of course prints out my name is
ellie that was all good totally worked
understood what was going on first
problem was when i suggested that she
write out a number instead
and when she wrote this she wrote write
26 but she put apostrophes around 26 and
i said
that's cool that totally works but
you don't need the apostrophes and she
said well why
and i sort of thought about it and
thought well that's a good question
and i thought about talking about the
historical reasons for why you don't or
the computational reasons why you don't
need
apostrophes around numbers in many
programming languages
but that was far too much detail and so
i asked her a bit more about what she
was thinking and it
it turned out that this apostrophe
notion was something that she clung onto
to understand what was going on in the
code so
to her and my dad apostrophes meant
inert or inactive
or literal whereas no apostrophes meant
active something like a variable or a
function name
and so the fact that there were no
apostrophes around the number 26 was
really confusing
because it seemed like it was going to
be active when actually it was a literal
so i've changed that in the language and
now you have to put apostrophes around
every literal this is my dad now
he's instantiating the name variable and
assigning it to richard
and then he's typing right name
and of course that prints out richard
when this happened it was kind of
profound actually it was a sort of
beautiful moment because he said
oh this is fun and you know i mean he'd
never done any programming before he's
and it seemed like he understood why it
was fun
and that i think brings in this idea of
indirection again where
again as i say you you do something here
and something
happens over here and there's magic in
between and that's why it's fun
and so it's kind of like setting up a
long line of dominoes all sat
all stood on their ends where you flick
one and you watch the whole of the rest
of them go
and i think that's why programming is
fun
now finally for this section metaphors
um
when i was working through the working
through teaching isla to ellie and my
dad
then um i found myself using metaphors
or analogies a lot
um so to explain variables then um
i used metaphors and i found that they
both responded to different types of
metaphors so
um ellie liked this notion of aliases
where the alias is like the variable
name and then the actual person
is the piece of data
whereas my dad preferred this notion of
bags where you've got a bag
and it's got the variable name written
on it and then you put the data in the
bag and that's like a variable
now the problem here is that these are
awful analogies that's not the way
variables work at all
um but i couldn't come up and think
better and then things got a little
worse
when i tried to explain references to my
dad so
in irela you can let's say you
instantiate two objects uh mary is a
person and eyler is a person
and then you say mary friend
isler friend is mary so friend the
attribute of isla
is um a reference so i
explain this to my dad that this notion
of maps where
maps as in treasure maps not uh hash
maps
and so i said a reference is kind of
like a map where you follow it to its
location
and it might produce another another
reference another map
and then you follow that one to where it
goes and maybe you get the actual piece
of data
and that's all good you know that worked
he understood what i was talking about
but it took like five minutes and a
proper backwards and forwards
conversation
and a diagram and so i'm really unclear
on how
i'm going to teach this stuff when i'm
not there to talk it through with the
person being taught
so that's totally an open question at
the moment there's a lot of open
questions with either really
which leads me to modes of expression um
final final topic
your mode of expression is the medium in
which you choose
to make the thing you're making so a
mode of expression is
as a film or as a novel or as a piece of
prose or as a poem
and you have to choose your mode of
expression extremely carefully
because your mode of expression dictates
your abstractions
now your abstractions are the building
blocks that you use to express
your idea so they're the sort of base
materials that you can
combine in some interesting way to
produce the thing you're trying to make
you know be
a novel or um microsoft word
or whatever um and so as programmers are
abstractions of things like variables
or functions or continuations or
closures
or libraries of code but the most
powerful abstraction that we have
um is the programming language we choose
to use
and it's a programming language is kind
of a meta abstraction really
and the reason for this is syntax
programming languages are really the
only way that you can control the syntax
that you use it's the only way you can
decide
what type of syntax you want to use and
the reason syntax is important is
because
it allows you to arrange your other
abstractions so
you've got your abstractions and they're
all well and good but you use syntax to
order them and thus produce what you're
making so to explain what i mean
um i'm going to talk about freeze frames
in film
so the freeze frame is being been being
used
for pretty much since feature films um
have were
started being made um and so by freeze
frame i mean the film
that you know you're watching a uh some
some film and the film's moving
and then it stops and you've got a still
image in front of you for a number of
seconds
so if you go back to 1947 when frank
capra made it's a wonderful life
then near the beginning of the film
there's a freeze frame of george bailey
the protagonist who's played by jimmy
stewart
and he's talking about the breadth of
his ambitions and he does this gesture
like this
but when he's speaking then he sighed
onto the camera as i am to you
and in this gesture there's a tiny
microcosm
of the whole film so what this idea
expresses
is that george bailey has these grand
umbre ambitions to build bridges
and to see the world but he in the end
forsakes them all
in in exchange for a life of great depth
so he stays in bedford falls
he marries the woman he's in love with
he raises some children
and he builds an altruistic business so
his life is not wide at all not not not
wide at all
it's actually very deep and so frank
capra
expressed a single idea with this freeze
frame um
it's a quite beautiful and subtle idea i
think but nonetheless it's a single idea
um if you come forward to 1992 when
martin scorsese made goodfellas
then you find freeze frames being used
in a far more subtle fashion
so there's freeze frames throughout
goodfellas
and what scorsese uses freeze frames for
is as a piece of syntax
as opposed to a piece of vocabulary and
this is the key difference
and the fact that uses the freeze frame
of syntax makes it a far more
powerful tool at his disposal so
to give you an example there's a freeze
frame and he uses
that as a piece of syntax to arrange his
vocabulary his building blocks
which are character points of view so
for example the film freezes and you've
got the narrator speaking which is one
point of view
you've got what the characters are
saying before the freeze frame and after
the freeze frame which is two more
points of view
and then finally you've got the actual
what's going on in the freeze frame
and see he's using the freeze frame to
arrange these pieces of vocabulary
into a far more complex construction
and so scorsese took the freeze frame
much further and this is why syntax is
important
because more powerful abstractions give
you more control over what you build
and abstractions suited to your work
give you even more control over what you
build
and so to me there's just an inevitable
conclusion here which is that you should
invent your own programming language
um or to put it another way and this is
this is the final thing i'm going to say
the value of greek prose composition he
said was not that it gave one any
particular facility in the language
that could not be gained as easily by
other methods but
if done properly off the top of one's
head it taught one to think in greek
once thought patterns become different
he said when forced into the confines of
a rigid and unfamiliar tongue
certain common ideas become
inexpressible other
previously undreamt of ones spring to
life finding miraculous new articulation
i will now take questions
was this the first language that you
wrote and was your
your motivation to to write a language
specifically for your niece and have it
ready when she's five or
was it really about this idea and then
you were like what language
um i thought for my development as a
programmer it would be good to write a
language i think everyone should write a
language
just for the learning experience i
thought it was my first programming
language and i'm stupid
then maybe i should start easy with a
programming language for children big
mistake it's i think it's far harder
so yes
anyone else uh one question what is the
sorry can you wave uh yeah what is the
next step i mean uh
what is the purpose for the language
right now you wanna
move into some schools and also show it
there you know and
under uh in the elementary level or
what's the idea um the idea is to the
the whole language is completely in flux
at the moment so i've got some syntax
and you can do useful stuff with it
but everything is up for debate at the
moment so i'm
quite wary of showing it to too many
people yeah i mean it's available on
internet at isla language.org but
um i don't want to show it too many
people because it's so unfinished
but so my next step is to try on as many
people preferably non-programmers and
young children
as possible to try and tune it okay we
have another question
way back here hi there i
really like your ideas especially about
kind of visual trickery and programming
environments
what do you think of scratch um is that
which one's that is that the i'm in the
scratch
programming environment for kids sure
i've looked at a number of languages um
uh that are for children and i sort of i
think i said it in my
in the talk that i feel like many of
them are taking the wrong approach with
starting with a gui
because i think that's not programming
and i don't think you get the magic
feeling of programming manipulating a
gui
and also i don't think you can produce
nearly as subtle constructions
so i'm trying to steer away from it from
all of those approaches essentially
any other questions there's a couple
here okay sorry
how long have we got sorry i have no
idea what the time is can we say yeah
we're doing okay for time
um so this is obviously in english i
mean it might be one of the most common
languages but
do you think it should be in the in the
native language of the children i mean
it's more difficult for a german child
to
understand the english language
definitely um so
the my idea is for this is that the key
words can be translated
into other spoken languages trivially
obviously but
the word ordering of different language
is different but nonetheless like
because there's only one way to do
everything
then i feel like the syntax won't be a
problem there and so
you could just change the word ordering
of each type of statement you can make
and change to keywords and you'd have
either in german
or any other language you choose
what are you what are your ideas to
bring the more complex
constructs of javascript or whatever
programming language
to children for example think about
recursions or
loops or whatever i mean is an
imperative language
the right way to teach that to children
or do we have to think more about
functional stuff what are you your ideas
about that
um my idea is that at the moment eiler
is purely a data definition language so
there's no control statements
there's no conditionals and i'm trying
to start with that core
and then build up adding things as i
figure out how to do them
in what i hope is an intuitive way so my
ideas are a complete model on the things
that you suggested at the moment
um so you you talked about how
eventually you want to teach it to or
you want to be teaching programming to
five-year-olds
um it seems like one of the the biggest
hurdles at
that age and teaching them with this
rather than with a uh a gui is just
going to be
like reading like at five a lot of kids
can't read that well and can't write
that well
um like what are your thoughts on that
definitely
um so i feel like
if children are learning to read at that
age then they could learn to program
in tandem with it and so i hope that
their programming ability would be able
to increase
with their reading and writing ability
um i haven't actually tried it with any
five-year-olds yet because it's not
nearly good enough for that yet
um so don't know yet
so you mentioned that you would like to
like write language that is similar to
natural language
but not quite because it might be
dangerous to actually make it feel like
natural language so
where do you actually find the balance
where
what's the kind of dividing point where
decides that's kind of the way it should
be
um the the rule i've taken is that
there's only one way to do everything
so there's only one way to construct
every piece of syntax
which i think hopefully is enough to
give the impression that you can't
um type whatever you want but still
totally under
i don't know whether i've made the
correct assumption there yet but that's
my sort of
dividing line um that i hope will keep
it from going into applescript territory
where which is just a mess
i have a question um you said there's
only one way to write
syntactically correct programs isn't
that uh curbing the
imagination of children or what's your
take on that um
sorry could you repeat the question yeah
so uh i thought you said that there's
only one way to write a correct syntax
for your programming language
isn't that curbing the imagination of
children um
i don't know
yes
i think quite obvious obvious question
why did you choose javascript to
implement this language
uh actually a bit of a confession the
original compiler is written in closure
um i uh ported it to javascript
so that i could submit it for a talk to
just